働いて子供だと その違う人を思っちゃうんですね
また会う時も違う人は違う人に会うんだけど
そこでまた子供に会ったと概念作る
その概念ずっとまた固めたら
これは私の子供ですよ
思ったところで まあずっと生まれた時から死ぬまで自分の子供という錯覚が生まれて
そこに執着が大変 苦しみが大変生まれてくるんですね
そこで離れなくなってしまっちゃうし
新しいエネルギー出てくるし
新しい活動しようとするし
だから知恵で発見してほしいのは
私も私という主体も 主体たるその現象も
客体たるこの見える現象も
全部瞬間だけですよと一回きりですよということは明確に体験することなんですね
それ明確に体験した人の無明は破れてしまうんですね
なくなってしまうんですね
そういうことで話戻りますけど
欲があるという あるならば怒りも生まれる
欲がある人に限って怒りが生まれるんですね
物は欲しがらない人にとっては
物を嫌うこともできなくなっちゃうんですね
欲しがる人には欲しがらないものは損害しちゃうんですね
ですから 働きは正反対ですけど
ラーガとドヴェッティガはまあ一つのコインの裏と表なんですね
それはなんで出てくるかというと
この最後に入ってるアヴィッジャ
無明だからなんです 無明っていうのは
この現象であることは分かってないんですね
分かりません それは 知恵というもの
発達しない限りは分かりません
で 他の だからそこら辺で大体終わりますけどね
まあ他のものはそれほど難しいサンヨージャナではないんです
次にあるのはマーナというサンヨージャナ
マーナというサンヨージャナがどのように生まれるかというと
私がいるという妄想概念から生まれるんですね
この私がいるというのは
仏教ではアスミーと言うんですね
アスミーっていうのは
あの 一人称単数形の動詞なんです
ですから アスミーっていうのは動詞だけなんですけど
その中に私はという意味も入ってるんです
文章で書けばアハン・アスミーなんですね
アハンというのは私はいるということ
で パーリ語ではこのアハン
私は 我々は あなたは あなた方は
彼は 彼らはというふうに別々に動詞が変わるんです
ですから 動詞だけで主語はわかるんです
そういうわけで この存在の哲学を考えることを発見することは
この こういう言語を使う人々にとってはいとも簡単なんです
で 存在はエネルギーだからね
エネルギーに照り合わせてエネルギーに言葉使ってるんだから
漢文では難しいんです
漢文はエネルギーに言葉ないんです
実体に言葉あるんですね
人とか家とか豚とか犬とかね
現象に形を入れてるんですね
歩くということは漢字で書けないんです
それで現象に想像しなくちゃいけないんですね
歩く いる 座るとかね 書けません
まあ動詞は必要ですから
漢字はありますけど その漢字はどのように作ったかというと
やっぱりある形から作ってるんですね
まああの それは置いておいて関係ない話だから
まあアスミーっていうのは私がいるということで
あの これは英語にすればアイムだけなんだよ
アスミーっていうのは
で アイムだけでわかるはずなんで
アイは要りません なお
現代英語ではいつでも主語が必要なんです
主語がなければ英語は成り立たないんですね
それで英語であろうか
ドイツ語であろうが フランス語であろうが
元で元のところで勉強しちゃうと
動詞の元の形が出てくるんですね
ですから be というんですね
この be 動詞ですね  be というんだけど
なんで be はいきなり am になるかっていうと
これすごいわかりにくいんです
で この存在に対するどんな言葉でも同じことで
で ドイツ語だったらseinですね
フランス語だったらêtreですね
で そこをまた私になったらêtreではなくてsuisというね S-U-I-S
になってしまっちゃうんですね
そういうのも変わっちゃうんです
それほど変わるのはもうかなり力入れてるんで
存在っていうことに かなり力入れて考えてるんです
だから私がいるという実感というのはすごい強いんです
そこでこのアスマイトということが私いるということ
私がいるという実感にアスマイトというんです
そこからマーナが生まれるんですね
で 私がいるという実感生まれたっていうことは
自分と他人を区別することなんですね
自分はだから瞬時に区別して離れて別にして考えちゃう
それで全ての問題が生まれてくるんです
それでマーナっていうのは測ることで
比べることで マーナの意味は私がいるということを前提として仮定して
すべての情報を比べてみるんですね
例えばこの音は綺麗で
この音は綺麗じゃないと
比べられないんです 私がいなきゃ
私にはこの音は綺麗です
私にはこの音は綺麗じゃないということなんですね
そこを忘れて 私にはということを忘れて
この音はいい音です この音はあまり良くないと
なんかすごい知識っぽく
そこで知識っぽく喋るんだけど
そちらにあるのは何と言いますか
その人の主観なんですね
決してそれは客観的な意見ではないんです
これは美味しくてこれは美味しくないということは
その言ってる人の主観であって
客観的な事実ではありません
じゃあ他人も食べてみて同じことを言ったら
それ客観的な事実になるかというと
それそうならないんです
それはもう一つの主観だけなんです
だから人間にとっては主観のみであって
客観的な事実はあるわけじゃないんです
主観というのは自分勝手に作るもので
あるものが美味しく感じようか
美味しくないように感じようかというのは
その人の勝手ですから
だからそこら辺事実だと私たちは哲学やら学問やら作ってるでしょうに
その主観を持って私はいるという概念を持って
我々は比べて比べていく
で 比べることによってまた新しいエネルギーが生まれてくる
いいと悪いと判断した
したところで じゃあどうすればいいかということはそこで出てきて行動を起こしちゃうんですね
だから行動は止まらなくなっちゃうんです
で 一般的にマーナに対して仏教でいうのは
自分が他人と同じだと理解すること
それから自分が他人より偉いと
あるいは自分が他人より偉くないと
優れてないというふうに比べることだそうですね
まあそれはすごいわかりやすいことで
です それによって人間はまた行動を起こしちゃうんですね
それまた九つに分けてるんですね
それも九つもそれほど大した分け方じゃないんですね
優れてる人と比べて その優れている人より私は優れてるんだと
で それとその人と私は同じだと
その人より私はレベルが低いんだと
それから同じだと思う人から比べて自分が偉いと
あるいは等しいと あるいはそれほどレベル低いと
低いんだと思うこと それでレベル低い人と考えて
その人より私は偉いとかね
そういう風に九つになっちゃうんです
それはセイヤマーナ サリサマーナ
ヒーナマーナと分けて
セイヤッサセイヤマーナ
セイヤッサリサマーナ
セイヤッサヒーナマーナとか
そういう風にパーリ語で簡単な言葉で分けてます
そこら辺はそんなに難しくないです
とにかくマーナが私がいるという実感なんです
で なんで私がいるという実感が生まれるかというと
やっぱりそこに私がいないんですから
見えたもの見えるだけのことで
全く別な働きであって
それは変化していって
二度と同じものを見えないし
聞こえたものは別な働きがあって
また二度と生まれませんしね
そういうものを生まれると私が見る
私が聞くというふうに感じてしまう
そこはまた無明からアヴィッジャから出てくるものなんですね
で 次の問題はディッティ
ディッティはもう一つ心の働きでいろんな意見作る
本当は何の意見も作られないはずなんです
花が綺麗というのはもう意見であって
それはその人がある現象を実体としてとってあるんだと思って綺麗だと判断すること
だから花が綺麗っていうのは
まあある人間の意見であって
それは正しい事実ではありません
ご飯は美味しいというのは人の意見であって
正しい事実ではありません
そういうわけで 人間にとってはもう意見はたくさんあるし
動物にもあるし そういうわけで
この誰も全生命が意見から脱出しているわけじゃないんです
私は別に何の意見も持ってませんよと言ったっても
そういうのはもう事実ではないんです
ただ便利に 便利で言う言葉だけなんです
[背景音楽]自分付き合ってる人々はいろんなことについてすごい違う意見を持っていて
まあどうしようもなくうるさいんだったら
自分がまあまあ楽にしようではないか
私は別にどんな意見も何も持てませんと
言うかもしれません だけど意見は持てないわけじゃないんです
意見持てないということには徹底した
このスケプティシズムでスケプティシズムでですか
このこの人間に知識はありえないということをおっしゃっていた人がいましたけど
インドではね スケプティシズム
日本語で何と言いますかね
うん 教無主義じゃないんだけど
懐疑主義 教無主義 うん
懐疑 懐疑 懐疑 まあ懐疑主義だそうですけど
で 何も意見持てないという立場なんです
で 何も意見持てないという立場を持つことも意見を持つことだから
それも否定するんですね
ですから このお釈迦様時代にいたこの人が言うのは
魂があるかというと 聞いたらあるとも思えないし
ないとも思えないし あるとないと両方でも思えないし
あるともない ないでもないとも思わないんだと
だからそうだとも思わない
そうではないとも思えないと
だからどのように質問しても
そうとも思わないという風に答える
だから立場というのは
やっぱり認識っていうのは不可能ですと
立場ですね だから仏教というのは大変この鋭くミドルパス中道をたどらなくちゃいけないんです
あ それはすごいと あなた言ってることはその通りだと
意見は持つわけにはいきませんという風に言っちゃった途端
懐疑主義に陥ってしまっちゃうんですね
だからといって仏教では何か意見持てるかというと持てないんです
大変難しいです 仏教の立場っていうのは
そういうわけで この生命っていうのは
何かものを見ると意見作る
この意見作ることの原因も
もう見えた 本当に見えたかという問題もあるし
その瞬間の現象 だからその瞬間の現象であるとあるということをわかる
たら それまた別なものと比べる必要またないし
まあ比べるのは構いませんだけど
まあ何か意見作る必要はなくなっちゃうんですね
まあ比べないんだ 例えば車とリンゴを比べるんだと
まあ比べないわけないんだけど
比べたって何の意味もないんですね
いくらでも比べられます
車とリンゴっていうのは
車は硬くてリンゴは硬くないとかね
車は動くんだけどリンゴは動きませんとかね
車は大きくてリンゴは小さいとかね
だから それで何かになるかって何にもならないんです
そこでリンゴは小さいんだという意見は
その車と比べた比べた時成り立つんであって
それはもう梅干しと比べたところで
いきなりリンゴが大きくなってしまっちゃうんですね
リンゴが大きくて梅は小さいということにまたなってしまっちゃうんですね
だからリンゴにおいて大きいか小さいかと意見作れなくなっちゃうんですね
で 味に比べたって車には味がなくて
リンゴには味があるんだと
それまた梅と比べたら
やっぱり梅の方には強烈な味があって
リンゴにはその比べるとそんな味がないということになってしまっちゃうしね
それでいかなる意見も本当は事実上は作れない
成り立たないはずなんですが
生きている私たちは意見で生きているんですね
ずっと必死になって意見を作る
意見を作って生きている
意見でなければ生きていられないんです
でも すべての問題の種も意見なんですね
そこでこの意見というか
見だけ使ってますけどね
仏教ではなくならば正しい正見という言葉もありますからね
だから正見は一見ではないかといえば
正見というのは見はなくなった状況に言う言葉だけであって
別に正見という別な意見あるわけないんですね
本当の状態を説明することを正見というんですね
そういうのはもう何回も説明します
仏教の場合はこの魂があるという意見がついちゃうでしょうね
それで大変なことになるんですね
魂があると思ったところで
で 魂のことを考えなくちゃいけない
あると思っただけなんですけど
あると発見したわけじゃないんです
それで思ったものはあるとまた勘違いする
であると思ったらあるならば
それはどのようなものかとまた考えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうし
全部根拠ない話になってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 宗教哲学っていうのはほとんど根拠ないところから始めて発達していって
人々に並ならぬ苦しみを作る道になっているんですね
それで魂があるということも邪見であって
魂がないんだということも邪見なんです
で とにかく何か意見 概念出来上がっちゃったら
それに基づいて人は生命生きていったりする
エネルギーが生まれる
それで輪廻に束縛される
じゃあそれから次にそれほど難しくないんですね
シーラブタ・パラマーサっていうのは
この 何て言いますか このいろいろ
行やら式だりやら習慣
生き方 そういうものにしがみついていることなんですね
業やら習慣やらしきたりやら
まあいろんな生き方に
何か目的がなければ そういうものには執着できないんです
例えば健康を目的にしちゃうと
いろんな生き方にとらわれてしまうんですね
健康的に言えば まあマイクロバイオティック食べなくちゃいけないと
それからこういう何か有機栽培の野菜を食べなくちゃいけないと
動物性タンパク質はもうやめなくちゃいけないとか
で そういう風に何か生き方を決めてしまうんですね
なぜ決められるかっていうと
何か目的があって 健康に生きていきましょう
そこで魂は清らかにしなくちゃいけないんかいけないんだと思ったら
どうすれば清らかになるかっていう
そこで生き方が現れてくるんですね
で そこは人間にはいつでもあるんです
何かに引っかかって何か生き方を探す
例えば別に宗教って何ですかとか
神道って何ですかとわからないんですけど
よく若者の手にもよくジュースお数を見えるんですね
はめてるんです まあそれなりに興味があるということは
私まあまあ若いんだけど
まあおしゃれはいっぱいしているんだけど
やっぱりそういう世界にも何か興味あるみたいなと
まあそこら辺はそういうそういう事実はあるんですが
やっぱりそれ一つはめたら何かいいことあるぞと思っている可能性もありますね
特にこのインドではね
人間考えたことは このとにかく変なことをやれば
それは普通の生き方と違う生き方だから
苦しみの道がなくなるんだと
例えば普通に食べて 普通に服を着て普通に生活すると
まあ苦しみの世界ではないかと
それだったら普通でないことをやろうではないかと
人は服を着るんだから
私例えば服を着ませんと
で 裸になる 人はご飯を食べてるんだから
じゃあ私たちは断食しましょうと
そういうことで戒律成り立っちゃうんですね
ほとんどの人は結婚しているんだから
じゃあ我々は結婚しないようにしよう
そういう風に作っている行は単なる行であって束縛されるだけですよ
それも真理はわからないんだからなんですね
だから人はご飯食べてるんだから
だから自分がご飯食べないんで断食しますよと言っても
そこで何の働きも心清らかなる働きが生まれてこないんですね
ですから 例えば仏教では
仏教だったらなんで人がご飯食べるかというと
生きているいるために生き続くためなんですね
それで断食するということは生き続けることをできなくなるんですね
それで結果としては死ぬことになるんですね
それだったらみんな生きていられる
生きたがる 私はじゃあ自殺すると
それで解脱やということになってしまっちゃうんですね
それで自殺することを解脱であるならば
みんな簡単に解脱する
なぜならば嫌だって死ぬんだから
そういうわけで断食は仏教でないんです
裸でいることも同じなんですね
なんで人は服を着るようになったかというと
やっぱりどんどん人間の体が変わっていって
寒さに暑さにまあ耐えられ
耐えられなくなっちゃったんですね
で 弱くなってしまったんですね
それで服を着て体を守るということになってしまったし
服を着ませんよと思ったことで体を守れないんですね
それで体は暑さにあたって大変苦しい状態になるか
病気になるか死ぬかと
寒さになって寒さにあたったら
真冬とかね この並の寒さじゃないんだからね
そこで人が死ぬ 死ぬほど苦しむか死ぬかどっちかなんですね
結果は それだったらまあ死んでもジャイナ教ではね
行を守って死んでも構いませんと
と言うならば 楽に死んだ方がもっと構いませんね
で 死ぬ死ぬ思い 死ぬことにチャレンジすることが
チャレンジしなくても死にますからね
そこで心清らかになるわけじゃないんです
これ 数珠なんかのことを見るとよくわかりますね
数珠を持った方が もうそれで大変落ち着きますよと思って
せっかく結んだから高いものを持とうと
思ったところで  10万円の数珠があったりして
50万円のお数珠があったりするんでしょうし
それでまた 100万円のものもあるんですね
そこで自分はどれぐらいしっかりしているかということを示すために
それにはお金がかかってしまっちゃうし
それでやって心が清らかになるかというと
またすごい屁理屈なんですね
それは新しい煩悩が生まれるだけです
高ければ高いほど数珠の徳が高くなるわけじゃないんです
高ければ高いほど それを守らなくちゃいけない
それなりに身や高慢やらね
で 出てくるし かえって余計な煩悩が生まれてくるし
そのようにこのいろんなしきだりに人間は掴まれて束縛されていますけど
中身は考えてないんですね
そういうことを言うんだけど
じゃあ仏教では何のしきたりも行儀もないかというと
また仏教は中道だから
一括で全部否定しているわけじゃないんですね
そこでまたすごい厳密にこの中道ということを立場で戒律やらしきたりやら決まってるんですね
いわゆるしっかり健康でいなくちゃいけないと
健康でいるためには食べ過ぎはダメよと
健康でいたっても 体の健康だけじゃなくて心の健康も必要ですよ
で 食べ過ぎだったら体も病気になるし
伴って心も病気になる
怠けてしまう それから食べることに執着したら
食べるものを探すために自分の生きる時間は全部それに使うし
そこで一生生きてて何をやったかと最後に聞いたら食い物探してたんだと
80年間も  80歳で死んだ人に聞けば
という結果になるんですね
そういうわけで 食べ物にあまり執着しないようにしましょうと
体維持する 維持できるぐらいで食べましょうと
体と心の健康を保たれるぐらいで食べましょうというふうなことで戒律が出ているので
だから目的 その場合はちゃんと合理的で明確なんですね
出家する人はなんで結婚し
なんで妻帯しないかと
したら まあ一生家族を守ることになってしまっちゃうんですね
だから何のために出家したんですかということになってしまっちゃうんですね
そこは変なことじゃないんです
例えば 軍隊に入ってる人々は仕事に行くと
奥さんと子供を連れて行けませんね
戦争に行く場合は じゃあいつ帰られるかわかりませんから
みんな一緒に行こうということにならないんです
そう言ったら仕事はできなくなるんですね
たとえ家族があっても
兵隊さんは家族を捨てていくんです
そうでないと仕事はできないんですね
ですから 出家という仕事を選んだら
また家族を守るという仕事はできなくなるんですね
まあいろいろそういうふうに
このこの仏教ではこういうサーンヨージャナというものをちゃんと勉強して
このサーンヨージャナをなくさなくちゃいけない
サーンヨージャナをなくすために必要な解毒剤を使うのであって
それは戒律に執着しているわけじゃないんです
例えば殺生してはいけませんと
殺生する場合は怒りで殺生するんですね
他人を殺してもいいと言った人がいてしまえば
まあどうせ死ぬんだから
先に殺したっても同じことじゃないかなと思ったら
まあその人はずっと怒りを成長させなくちゃいけないんです
で パティグがある人には解脱はできないんですね
嫌なものを殺さなくちゃいけないんだから
それでやっぱり殺生してはいけないという戒律というものは
まあ有意義な意味のある戒律になってしまっちゃうんです
インドのことを言うと
やっぱり犬の行をやったり
牛の行をやったりしたんだそうですね
人間やってることとは違うことをやるんではやりましょうと
そこで犬のように生活する行者たちが出家して
だから戒律の先生は犬なんですね
そこら辺考えないで 犬がやるように全部やる
寝る時は犬が寝るように寝る
食べる時は犬が食べるように食べる
それで喋れません 犬は喋れませんだから
で アジェブッタ・ゴーブッタとワタとかね
まあ書いてましたけどね
で あることあるんだけど
このまあ 冷凍師出てくるのは一人の人だけなんです
一人の人がこの犬のように業やっていたんだと
大変人気が出たんですね
かなり長い間 長い年月
犬のように生活していたんですね
それで彼にお布施する場合はご飯持ってきてちゃんと混ぜて
まああげるんですね あげたら口で食べるんですね
手は使わない 食べて何も喋らないで
そのままどこかで寝てしまう
それで他の人々はこれは阿羅漢ですよ
聖者ですよ なぜならば簡単な理由
世の中のことからきれいさっぱりもう離れているんだから
仏教から見れば まあただの犬を先生にして
犬をモデルにして一人だけではないかと
違うことをやったんだからといって偉いわけじゃないんだと
ということで その人は悟ってるんだと言ったところでお釈迦様は何のことなく
そいつは一週間で死にますよと
それで地獄に落ちるんだと
地獄の名前まで言って書いてしまったんです
その人に先生説法しようと
それもそこまで行かなかったんで
もう治りませんだから
二十年ぐらい自分やっていた業をやめるわけ
やめませんだからね 言ったらお釈迦様嫉妬しているんだと
そこをバレるんだと まあ将来のことを予言しましたからね
言ってそのお釈迦様の弟子一人でしたけど
彼がその人に報告するんで
あんたのことをお釈迦様は予言しましたと
一週間で なんていますか
食べ過ぎになって消化不良で死ぬんだと
ただその人もバカだから
じゃあ食べ過ぎになって消化不良で死ぬというならば
私は一週間食べないようにしますと
そこで一週間も信者さんがずっとついていたんだから
ご飯持ってくるは食べない
問題は言えないんですね
喋ったら戒律は犯しますからね
で このお釈迦様のそばにいたこの弟子があの人を見たらすごい阿羅漢だと思ったところであ羅漢ですねと感動したところでお釈迦様怒ったんではなくてね
もう何のことなく もうあいつは一週間で消化不良で死んで
なんとかで地獄名前ってね
その地獄に落ちますよと言って
その弟子がその人に言ったんですね
言ったことは理解できますから
彼も まあじゃあざまあみろということで
もう断食始めた 食べないでいたんです
それ 信者さんに言っておけばよかったんだけど
それは言えないでしょうね
食べない だから信者さんがどうしようかな
この仙人が食べないんだと
次の日も食べ物持ってくる
食べない 一週間も食べなかったんだから
一週間目はものすごい
もうどうせ好き嫌いわかってるんだから
すごいありとあらゆるご馳走を作って持ってきたんですね
一週間も食べてなかったんだから
ものすごいもう食欲があるし
また食べては寝るだけの仕事だから
あの それなりに体も結構出来てだろうと思うしね
だからもう我慢できないんですね
この食べ物の香りが鼻に来るわ
もうずっとどうぞどうぞ召し上がってくださいとみんな言ってるわ
じゃあしょうがないんだから
まあちょっとだけ食べますと
という気持ちで食べたんだけど
消化不良で死んじゃったんです
一週間ダメな人はもう食べてはいけませんだから
本当はもう粥とか何か水ね
液体のようなものしか食べてはいけませんだからね
消化不良で死んじゃって地獄に落ちたんだそうです
それでもお釈迦様の弟子はそれでも納得いかない
で 遺体のところに行って
あんた本当にこういう地獄に落ちたんですかと聞いたら
そこでお釈迦様がやっぱりその死んだ人に地獄からあの立ち上がれと言ってね
立ち上がって この遺体にまた乗り移って
本当は私はそういう地獄には落ちてるんだと言って
また倒れたんだそうですけどね
まあそういうストーリーあるんです
とにかくそれ経典に入ってるストーリーなんです
で その煩悩っていうのは
またそういう特定の人にある煩悩といったらまた勘違い
この戒論衆というこの煩悩が全ての生命にあるんです
私たちはただやらないだけのことで
心の中にあるんです 何か少々違うことをすればいいんじゃないかな
であるということはわかるのは
誰かが特別に業やってるんだと
三ヶ月間こもって何か業やってるんだと
千日業やってるんだとか
何とか聞いたらすぐ あ
それはすごいと  [背景音楽]